won't say that everything's perfect
right now but i'm just saying it's like
a different time and it's crazy it's
so much [ __ ] better for me john yeah
i mean i don't want to cry right now
but there was a time john
where i was like i think i'm out
i mean she was with me i would like wake
and go i would like a year would go by
not a single audition
and i would look at her and this is
after all the [ __ ] that i've done and
i'd just be like i think i'm out it's
kind of why we started this podcast
really he really had you know nothing
going we were like do you think it's
because you don't have any talent do you
think that
i was thinking
i was
i was thinking that but i think what it
was is
i made something that had nothing to do
with the hollywood machine yeah right
and i gathered
the fans on my own these are legitimate
you
you you organically made the new model
for hollywood which is you do something
and then people come to you and go can i
have a piece of that yeah
and whereas before we were going can i
have a piece please may i i know i know
but this is so funny because this is
turning into a therapy session for me
too because i would have thought yeah
you know i was looking at you going this
guy has it better than me and the reason
i thought that was like i always felt in
between in terms of my type or whatever
i was always caught between comedy and
drama and i was like i can't i don't
like i can't seem to aside from harold
and kumar which
i
kind of barely got and was like i don't
know if i did a good job in that yield
thank you but like i i i look back and
i wasn't a great straight man i was
trying to be funny
i i should have played it dead straight
dead dry
bone dry but i i was like this is a
comedy i'm supposed to be i didn't know
what i was doing yeah but anyway like i
i was i always felt like
okay which way am i supposed to go
and i looked at you and i thought this
guy's funny like that that should be a
clearer path and i would have thought
that you had it better i did i was
looking at you gone because i would i
while you're
doing what you're doing i don't know
what you're doing all right
i'm sure you're doing great things
but you're doing your great things i was
in
peoria at the chuckle [ __ ] factory
you mean trying to sell 20 tickets yeah
you know what i mean i mean there were
some desperate times where i'd be in a
town remember i played this place called
bananas yes i remember and then they had
the folding seats yeah and then the host
goes
call me jimmy knee
like i'm headlining my name's on the
thing he's like jimmy knee
and i walked up and i'm going and there
was like 10 people in the audience i'm
like and this is in my 40s yeah yeah
yeah yeah we were there i'm in my 40s
going oh this is it this is the last one
wow but then what ended up happening is
we started this
and then
things just started selling out
and i i'm just so thank you so much
you're welcome she made me do this oh
really well we didn't have
we didn't have a choice we were staring
at each other all day like what are we
gonna do like all day long let's just
get some mics then
and then whatev you know then you know
we built this thing and now it's all
come back it's really weird but that's
awesome dude thank you i'm so happy for
you can i tell you another thing that
you did
okay
i will say by the way i'm not immune to
getting my name mispronounced uh there's
a i'm thinking of an actor i once said
his name i'd
worked with him multiple times
uh and uh
i ran into him at a restaurant he said
johnny [ __ ] cha
i'm so confident really
big big slap
okay yeah yeah uh but
why didn't you recorrect them
the same reasons
i do it depends on who it is
if you're a comic yeah an open micro
yeah call me by my say my real name but
give me a different last name go ahead
give it up for bobby knee
oh my god i'm so sorry that's how i do
it [ __ ] wait a second how do you know i
didn't correct him i didn't say that
oh excuse me my friend
did you correct him no i didn't
i know
you guys at nights like if without calm
the app i cannot go to sleep they have
the best
sleep stories they have the best
soundscapes
you know what they have now is they have
dune soundscapes ooh yeah so where if
you you could be on um what's the planet
where the the dune is at